the twin brothers famously lost out to
Mark Zuckerberg in a battle for the
fortune generated by Facebook but they
did walk away with millions of dollars
and where they put that money as a story
of its own it's detailed in the new book
Bitcoin billionaires by author Ben
Mezrich who also wrote the accidental
billionaires the book on which the
social network was based Ben Mezrich
welcome back to the show thank you very
much another fascinating subject here
you write about about the Winklevoss
twins that they were a book cover that
had already been judged and judged again
what was the perception of them after
Facebook so it was really my fault
actually
when I first met the wink of iTunes I
grew up on 80s movies and they were the
immediately the bad guys I know they
looked like the guys in skeleton
costumes chasing the Karate Kid around
the gym and and when I wrote accent oh
billionaires you know they were the
alpha males they were these you know
almost a joke I think that carried
afterwards everyone saw Zuckerberg is
the lovable nerd yeah and them as the
bad guys but that was actually wrong I
love the plural the Winkle that we
provide I mean the whole notion of
Bitcoin and cryptocurrency the idea that
they caught on to this on vacation right
they went to what happened was they got
this settlement for 65 million dollars
which they took in stock so it became
five hundred million dollars well then
they tried to invest in Silicon Valley
but no one would take their money
because they were the guys Zuckerberg
hates the most so no one wanted them on
their spreadsheet and no one wanted to
upset Chuck right so they went to Ibiza
as one does on the beach and someone
walked up and said have you heard of
Bitcoin right and that started this
crazy journey into this digital currency
and turned them into multi billionaires
and on that journey we sort of see that
their differing thoughts about what
people believe Bitcoin should be right
what are some of those right well
Bitcoin started from this libertarian
anarchist place where people used it to
buy drugs on something called Silk Road
people thought it's a way to bring down
governments bring down banks right but
the wincle vite wins are the guys in
suits they wore suits to class they're
the ones thinking that bitcoin can
actually be a part of the financial
system it's digital money money I can
send directly to you yeah with nobody in
between and that to them is a
liberating thing that everyone could use
and help get him back in with the people
in Silicon Valley that shunned them
earlier well what's crazy is now
Facebook is looking at doing a digital
coin or a crypto coin and supposedly
it's been reported and it's actually
partly in my book that that Zuckerberg
has now been talking to the wincle but I
believe it's always been personal
between the twins and Zuckerberg
that they're both driven by this
personal battle going on the
Shakespearean battle between the twins
and Zuckerberg and it's never gonna end
there's another fascinating character in
the book Charlie Shrem
he was profiled on 60 minutes actually
last Sunday what does he represent in
the world a Bitcoin yeah so Charlie
Shrem was this very smart young guy he
was 19 years old lived in his mother's
basement and he was one of the first
people into Bitcoin he built a company
called bitinstant but he went the wrong
way he was sort of dragged into the
libertarian anarchist fold and ended up
making mistakes ended up being the first
person to go to jail for Bitcoin he was
the third partner of the wink of I twins
so it's a big part of this story they
were trying to bring him to the right
side but we're pulling him the other
during the dark side yeah well there
have been a few transformational events
in Bitcoin talk to us about Silk Road
and so yeah so originally Silk Road was
the only place you could really use
Bitcoin Silk Road was an underground
dark web site where you could buy and
sell anything
I mean drugs and guns and all sorts of
illegal stuff and in the beginning
that's what Bitcoin was all about now
that was taken down at a big FBI raid
the guy who founded it ended up going to
jail for multiple life sentences but the
twins always saw that as a good thing
when Silk Road went away that meant
Bitcoin could become something
mainstream regular people are not going
to use Bitcoin right if it's being used
to buy drugs are they still billionaires
yes they are
bitcoins back up at $8 in Bitcoin
millionaires eight point thousandaire
the coin hundred Aires
this sounds much better Benjamin thank
you very much I appreciate it